- A network of
volunteers in Phoenix, Arizona
has mobilized to help migrants
once they're released from
ICE detention centers.
But they have been
forced to go underground
because they've been
targeted by armed protesters
critical of their work. Regardless,
they are determined to help migrants
dropped off in their city.
- Every day I get a text message
from my ICE contact.
She will let me know how many people,
what hours, and the location that
they'll be dropped at.
- We created this amazing system
where everything was put in place.
- We provide a place where people can
rest, eat, sleep.
- Set up our little pop-up pharmacy.
- Prepaid phone kits.
- Somebody needs drivers or we need
more volunteers (snaps fingers)
we radically mobilize.
(snapping music)
- [Narrator] Volunteers
adapt to the government's
constantly changing immigration protocols.
They provide food,
lodging, medical support,
showers, clothing, cellphones and
transportation for migrants.
And they do it without any government
funding or support.
- We have an incredible
group of volunteers.
I mean, there are over 500 people who are
chomping at the bit to be involved.
- We do this because we love it.
But we were putting a Band-aid
on what the government was doing.
- Every time we make adjustments
to accommodate, however,
ICE and Border Patrol
are choosing to process people.
The goalposts just keep moving.
- We will just get our hands on managing
200 people a day, and then all of a sudden
we're told that the
numbers are going to jump.
- [Narrator] Over 25,000
migrants have been released
by ICE in Phoenix
in the past four months.
Some days, more than 300 people are
dropped off at local churches.
But when those are full or unavailable,
they're left outside this
Greyhound bus station.
- On one hand, it's disheartening that
we have to step in, but on the other hand,
I am so moved by all of
the people that I've met.
They are all people who
care about immigrants.
- Food is love.
You know, you feed somebody and you
are telling them that you care about them.
I called up all different kinds of people.
I called up my Methodist friends,
my Catholic friends, and my Sikh friends,
and my Jain friends, and
my friends who are atheist
and I said, 'This is a
humanitarian crisis.'
Right now we're serving a meal to them
and this is something that's important.
And everyone started coming.
- While many of the pop-up
shelters are churches,
volunteers come from
all walks of life.
Some have immigration
stories of their own.
- I'm a DACA recipient.
I came here when I was four with my
mom from Mexico.
We actually crossed through Arizona
and we were apprehended.
We were actually in the detention center
that a lot of families here have been in.
To me, helping migrants is personal.
It's returning the cycle
of where I came from.
I see the ICE truck coming and
I see people staggering out.
They look so confused.
And the first question he asked me is,
'Where am I?' I said, 'You're in Arizona.'
And I remember them telling us how
cold it was. That awakened my memories.
I was like, I have to step up,
I have to do something.
- I'm an immigrant originally from Syria.
When I'm meeting people and we're
working with them to get them situated,
I see myself, I see my relatives,
I see my friends and I
want to do better by them.
I want this country to do better by them.
Not being able to do anything about
what was happening in Syria, but
being able to do something here,
just seeing the parallels and the journeys
that people are facing.
Migration is a human right and
it's everybody right to flee to safety
when they feel unsafe.
- Arizona has a history of
strict immigration policy.
In 2010, the state passed S.B. 1070,
which requires immigrants to have their
immigration documents
on them at all times.
It also required police to verify
immigration status during lawful stops
and detainments if there
was "reasonable suspicion"
the person was in the country
without authorization.
- I think that Arizona is
looked at as the Wild West.
You know, people see us as
gun-toting conservatives
that are sort of anti-Brown people.
- I grew up in LA and
I remember they would
always tell you, 'Stay away from Arizona.
Don't go to Arizona
because of the political
atmosphere and the hateful rhetoric toward
immigrants.' Arizona is
so much better than that.
- Arizona also has a
history of helping migrants, dating
back to the Sanctuary
movement in the 1980s and '90s
when an underground network of churches
housed Central American immigrants fleeing
from violence and oppression
in their home countries.
Today, churches still lead
the movement to help migrants.
- The Sanctuary movement started because
the United States was refusing to allow
people to make asylum claims.
This is different because now we've got
people that are being
allowed an asylum hearing.
Border Control is sending them to ICE.
Immigrations Custom Enforcement
is sending them to us.
So what we're doing is perfectly legal.
In fact, what we're doing is supporting
the government rather than
thwarting the government.
As we've done this work, there's a group
of armed protesters that
shows up to churches.
- Members of
the Patriot Movement AZ,
a group that the Southern
Poverty Law Center
classifies as a hate
group, has threatened,
followed, and filmed
volunteers and migrants.
In response, volunteers went underground,
keeping names, locations and other
details of their work secret.
- We aren't able to use
the traditional route
of crowdfunding or getting Facebook.
If we do, then the Patriot movement
shows up.
- As the asylum refugees
were getting off the
ICE bus, they had their phones out,
they were taking photos of them.
They were yelling at
them, 'You're murderers,
you're rapists.' Things like that.
None of these people are like that at all.
- I get targeted.
They'll put my name out and say,
'This is a person who help migrants,
another illegal helping illegals.'
See these people coming in and telling me
that something bad's gonna happen to me,
following me, taking pictures of me,
going up to me with weapons on hand.
I'm not scared anymore.
My ideology, my love is way stronger than
whatever hateful rhetoric
they come at me with.
- I worry that someone's going to get
hurt because of the protesters.
But ultimately, what keeps me going is
knowing that we've got these moms
and babies, dads that are protecting
their little girls.
- Migrant drop-offs
in Phoenix aren't new.
Some volunteers have been coordinating
drop-offs with ICE since 2013.
But now, release procedures change
more rapidly.
In just the past few
weeks, ICE drastically
reduced drop-offs in Phoenix only to
increase drop-offs in Yuma, a border city.
Yuma has since declared
a state of emergency
due to the sudden influx of migrants.
- The people who are helping are not the
heroes of the story.
The actual heroes are the people
who are willing to
leave everything behind
and take a risk and face danger so that
they can have a safer
future for their children.
And I really hope that
we can change policies
so that nobody has to be dropped off.
I think the goal of any group that
comes together to serve others
is to have an impact on policy so that
their group doesn't have to exist.